SUBU O TODAY.
WE HAVE MO BG WS A
WELL.
>>> THISLSNTO THE "CNN
658 PE IN AT LEAST 35
SS
INROTESTRI.NG TO AN
BEEN S
DABEING AGSOME NEWS IS GETTINGSI
IT LED ONET FOSMRUSSIA.DOESN'T E
S" AND MOVED REPORTERSUTF TH
COUNTRY FOR THNG.
CNN SAID WARUTNGUR MOSCO BUTE
E  IMPACT OF
THAT IISTURB
RUSSIA RIGHT.
SAERE ARNALISTECIDEDO STAY, PERD
E OF THOSEYGENIAITS.
SHELWHICH COULD BE AIO
AWIT COULD HAVE HER D D RSS ABLN
HAVE E TO S
LEFT.
TELL US WHATHE EN LIK OF YOUR O
F VING ME. IT'T OU0, THESOWO
D, SOMOFHEM, Y JUST AROW.TO BH
CI ME L IS KEEP  SO I CAN
WSCAN MAKED I
I'M ANSOI KNOW HOWUS K A VL
YOU FOR SURE I DON'T
N MOSCOW.NHA I
E A LOT S AND
EARS ON THE GROUND IENRE?
E MP
YOU SEEING FOOD RU
OTIN
YES,LDTELL YOU FORE
AND IT WAS REAL  RUSSIANS
TO FIND OUT
JUST IMAGINE FORT OKNOWSLOW CHA.
IS1 TIME
T NOTHIN IMPORTSWHATSOEVER.
HI USEARE EITHER UNDER SANCTION.
E O E S O CUT NG
ARE SLOWLY SEEING -- YOUEAT THAW
IN MORE AFFLUENTRE
STATES AHEHE UNI
WHAT'S HAPPENING TMAUPN, IT'PRED
THY LVIVSTERDAE WA
LUHANSK SEANST THE
IS GOING TO TH WHAT MAKES EA.
T  IT'
.
OULD TYOE UPIN THES  U
IS IREALLY HNI THA
RU ARE K
UKIA FAMLLY FR
E HEWORLD
WAR II IIN
MYKO WHEREY  ANDOINGHT NOWNDS W
OLUTELY
>> DO NEIGHBORS BELIEVE
IHAE THERE HAVE BN REPORTTHATYE
THAT THE WAR IS RAGING.
AT THE SAME TIME, GHSTATE VIN S
THEITUNE ANDALK ABDAPULL
OUT THE TROOPS F
R HBS?ULDERSTAO
CHLSE CL
JUSTTHING .
E JUSTTEA
E ANNA RUSSIANIOOO
NATIONALS DID POHOA DEST THEL D
IT AE OF MS THEY KNOW, CAN YOTOE
KN, IF YOU HAVA
VITWORESLENOLOGY AHEY N NDN SOMT
, SSMYNDRAS AVO INVADERE YOU AF
ANYTHING.
YOU KNOW, IT'S TOO LFO
TO B TOO
KNOW,'V ITIO THI
MY ENTLIFE.
WAS PUTIJUST
WROTE E , WHAT A Y? JUS
IN, ITE E CORPORAT  OVER.RATION
HEN E MOST POWL
ANDS  USE TECHNOLOGY, TO C
ND
IT'SLSO AN INSTITUTION WD ON VI.
THAD OF THPR TION AND THIYOU ,
ANDO S G D
IS UNDEROL.N WORRY
THAT'STHATHA
YOU WHICO THATIOANNOT S IN MYN A
ALRESEAN.OW, NO PROMISED
ME THAM GOING
W
TO ME TH I TAFNDS E LIKE MAY COU
ENT SENSE TH I SNTRA.
O BADLI UNDERSTAND THAT -- UEN
I WAS A KID,EN
WHEN I WAS A WREPORTER, WHENAS .
NO KNK -- WHEN
I FEEL KNOW,
I'MYS G THU GUYSNDT  ID.Y TH REG
WHAT'S HAPPENING, YO, THEYOU KNI
>>OU. TSTOUAVD USE.